stéphane le foll le porte parole du
gouvernement et le ministre de
l'agriculture est l'invité de preuves
par 3 bonsoir bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous pour ce rendez-vous de public
sénat avec l' agence france-presse
trois grandes parties et chacune d'elle
une question première question la loi
travail at elle encore un avenir entre
les opposants qui n'abandonne pas la rue
et le medef qui aujourd'hui vous lancent
un ultimatum deuxième question pouvez
vous nous confirmer que votre cri ou
votre sos face aux divisions de la
gauche est bien et au la gauche 1 avec
ce meeting annoncé lundi soir vous le
dirai à oriane mancini de public sénat
enfin troisième question la crise
agricole est ce que le pire en fait est
encore devant nous avec les difficultés
notamment des secteurs du lait ou des
céréales et là vous répondrez à anne
chaon de l' agence france-presse
mais d'abord donc la loi travail entre
deux contestation celle des opposants
donc qui ont déjà connu une nouvelle
date à la fin du mois et puis celle
désormais du medef qui vous lance un
ultimatum pour des corrections favorable
aux entreprises
c'est ce que dit pierre gattaz ans les
côtes et vous répondez nous avons
atteint aujourd'hui notre point de
rupture
si rien ne bouge rapidement sur ce texte
dans les trois semaines qui viennent
nous en tirons les conséquences et le
gouvernement et les députés récolteront
ce qu'ils ont semé
nous pourrons alors demandé
officiellement le retrait du texte d'un
évidemment mais au-delà de ça je pense
que le dialogue social institutionnel
risque d'en bâtir beaucoup et que nous
demandons sans doute la suspension des
négociations assure au chômage alors que
répondez-vous à pierre gattaz qui n'en
peut plus des retraits et des ajouts
dans le texte un qui vont pas du tout
dans le fort des entreprises dit il
d'abord c'est la surprise la surprise
que monsieur gattaz se met dans la
situation où la position de demander le
retrait du texte ce texte qui vise il
vous l'avez rappelé aussi un d'autres
demandent le retrait ils sont dans la
rue monsieur gattaz cent des raisons
reposer pour des raisons opposées ça
veut dire que quelque part dans ce texte
il
à la fois ce que nous cherchons à faire
c'est à dire donner aux entreprises d
souplesse nécessaire pour leur permettre
d'embaucher et en même temps donner aux
salariés dé sécurité qui fasse que en
particulier avec le compte personnel
d'activité on est des droits nouveaux
qui soient garanties pour les salariés
alors ça ne comprend que d'un côté le
medef dit non au droit supplémentaire et
que certains dans la rue disent non à
des souplesses ou entreprises nous voilà
exactement là où on peut faire le
constat qu'en france sur un sujet on
peut parier américains et bien on se
retrouve avec des intérêts totalement
opposés et une volonté d'empêcher de
trouver les compromis nécessaires donc
je ne comprends pas la position de
monsieur ouattara est aujourd'hui les
compromis vous les avez surtout fait aux
manifestants qui sont descendus dans les
rues à la preuve c'est qu'il ya toujours
des manifestants dans la rue qui disent
qu'on avait les périodes comparables
dont voilà trop comment ils veulent le
retrait décidément c'est devenu le
slogan mais je le rappelle ce texte
c'est de la souplesse pour les
entreprises nécessaire pour qu'elles
puissent créer de l'emploi et en même
temps des garanties aux salariés
c'est aussi clair simple que ça alors
vous évoquez le compte personnel
d'activité donc le medef n'en veut pas
mais surtout il ne veut pas de la
taxation accrue des cdd est ce que là
vous pourriez bouger alors c'est assez
paradoxal là encore stéphane le foll
parce qu'on le sait beaucoup député
socialiste est le premier d'entre eux ma
main à leur cher bruno le roux sont
contre cette taxation à disposition des
gosses alors c'est un principe qui a été
posée par le premier ministre qui
nécessite une négociation qui avait déjà
eu lieu puisque cette taxation
oui cela pourrait la faire entrer dans
la loi et les députés veulent pas il ya
un débat parlementaire qui s'engage donc
c'est assez incompréhensible de la part
de monsieur gattaz puisque vous venez
vous même de le dire dans ce débat
parlementaire
il ya des parlementaires qui s'exprime
vous pouvez être assurés alors je vais
pas le rassurer je vais simplement lui
rappeler que dans une démocratie
lorsqu'une loi a été déposée au conseil
des ministres qu'elle est en phase
d'avoir été étudiée d'ailleurs dans les
commissions compétentes au niveau de
l'assemblée qui va rentrer dans le débat
plénier
il est quand même inconcevable difficile
à comprendre qu'on dise on demande
l'arrêt d'un débat au parlement
c'est quand même peut-être une première
rien eu
surprenant surprenant d'autant il vous
l'avez rappelé que dans ce débat en
particulier sur la question des
taxations sur les cdd qui a des députés
de la majorité qui se sont exprimés donc
le débat est ouvert
quelle est votre position au gras
mangerai pas de position sur le sujet
mais c'est le gouvernement effectivement
ce mineur en le votant avec
l'intégration accrue des seuils
d'imposition qui existait déjà
oui mais on voulait la faire entrer dans
la loi ces différentes je le rappelle
qu'il existait déjà elle avait été le
fruit d'une négociation pour faire en
sorte que les entreprises ne renvoie pas
en multipliant les cdd la responsabilité
de gérer ensuite le fait que des
salariés se retrouvent dans des périodes
de non activité sur l'ensemble des
droits qui sont liées aux chômeurs et
qui donc nécessite aussi la
mutualisation de cerises à l'heure vous
trouvez inconcevable qu'une organisation
patronale demande le relais de retrait
d'un texte très longs trajets à
l'assemblée nationale est en débat à
l'assemblée nationale que pensez vous
alors de ce même patronat qui menace de
quitter les négociations sur l'assurance
chômage
si vous gardez ce statu quo mais les
négociations sur l'assurance chômage
par définition elle s'engage entre
partenaires sociaux
ici la france à un progrès majeur
affaire c'est que elles finissent par
comprendre en tout cas dans les acteurs
qui sont liées à l'activité économique
que c'est par la défense d'intérêts qui
sont sous les entreprises et ceux des
salariés la nécessité de trouver des
compromis qu'ont avant mais là il est
prêt à claquer la porte et l'eau me met
hors jeu j'ai bien entendu vous
inquiétez pas j'ai pas le gouvernement
est prêt à prendre la relève par exemple
à prendre la main sur règne aussi sur
l'unedic s'engage et qui doit s'engager
l'unedic c'est un système paritaire qui
fait que les entreprises payent des
cotisations et que ces cotisations
permettent de dresser pour les chômeurs
des prestations bon donc celle
équilibres financiers du système qui est
en négociation entre les partenaires
sociaux
par définition ils doivent négocier mais
il voudrait de ce fait les coins mais à
ce moment là ça veut dire qu'il faudrait
que ce système paritaire disparaissent
qui s'arrête c'est ma question est ce
que vous avez en europe 1 je n'ose même
pas l'imaginer
vous ne verrez pas les noms sur une voie
qu'on a choisi qui consiste à trouver
et a poussé dans le dialogue social à
faire en sorte que les compromis arrive
à se faire et à se nouer mais là dans le
cas de rupture le point de rupture mais
il apparaît comme ça d'un seul coup un
après midi puisque mauvais dans une
réunion avec des périodes de crise
comprenez pas c'est surprenant oui et à
ses goûts 2 comment dirais je
surprenant et on peut très bien
compréhensible qu avez vous pensé que le
patronat manque de gratitude après les
baisses de charge lors être accro mais
moi j'attends pas du patronat du crédit
du nord
j'attends ça mais bon en fait que
l'économie française fonctionne mieux
que les entreprises et des marges
qu'elle ait été reconstituée pour leur
permettre d'investir et créé dans le mot
c'est ça que j'attends valeur jeu
je n'attends rien du patronat bon alors
vous estimez en tous les cas que les ce
nouveau dérapage 1 sur le chemin déjà
bien compliqué de cette fois travail
n'est pas imputable aux concessions que
vous avez faites aux syndicats de l'île
non à ce qu'on reste sur un bilan en
équilibre qui vous est vrai à aller plus
loin on en a parlé cette semaine avec un
rapport qui était repris au premier
ministre premier au premier ministre est
ce que vous êtes prêts à faire une
promesse pour 2017 pour permettre que
les jeunes à partir de 18 ans touchent
le rsa ce que ça viendra marquer les
dépose et boeing doivent être étudiant
mon grand-père qui fait des propositions
pour simplifier l'ensemble des minima
sociaux les simplifiée puisque cette
complexité fait aussi qu' une partie de
ses droits ne sont pas accessibles donc
il faut simplifier ça c'est une demande
générale mais ça fait partie aussi des
engagements du président de la
république donc il faut simplifier avoir
un contrat socle me paraît une bonne
idée de dire que chacun va y avoir le
débat l'emportent sur les mini spéciaux
pour les jeunes et le débat était dans
le rapport et des propositions faites
bien le premier cela dit tout ça va être
étudiée étudié en fonction est ce que
c'est pour vous une solution pour aider
les jeunes à lutter contre la pauvreté
stéphane le foll est ce que il faut
multiplier les aides ou et essayer au
contraire de favoriser le plus possible
l'entrée dans l'entreprise d'une
embauche c'était le projet initial de la
loi elle comme ça reste le programme
initial de la loi et quand je vois pas
pourquoi cet objectif aurait changé à
leur aisance de le même dans ce contexte
il ya peut-être un point d'accord entre
vous le gouvernement et le medef c'est
la critique de la radicalisation de la
cgt la cgt très hostile on le voit
actuellement son congrès à marseille
hostiles au patronat hostile également
ouvrir davantage savourer une ia leur a
coûté ce que je pense surtout c'est que
la cgt dans la position qu'elle a prises
extrêmement dur dans un discours très
dur avec tout ce qu'il ya à côté
cette affiche aussi on va la voir là qui
dénonce l'agression initiale on la
regarde une position très sectaire est
très dur mais au fond c'est toujours la
même question est-ce que ça va servir
les salariés je ne le crois pas parce
que les salariés ils ont besoin tous les
salariés qui sont aujourd'hui tous
savent très bien qu'ils ont besoin
d'avoir des entreprises qui fonctionnent
qui créent de l'emploi qui embauchent et
que donc si on n'est pas capable de se
mettre au tour de table pour négocier et
ceci étant dit quand je le dis en même
temps que je le dis je sais que des
fédérations de la cgt
quand il s'agit négocié négocie dans les
entreprises
c'est donc je trouve que cette position
cette posture d'entrée au congrès n'est
pas un sujet pour le gouvernement c'est
plutôt à qui tout ça ne donnera pas de
droits supplémentaires de capacité à
négocier c'est plutôt salariés à l'heure
vous avez évoqué la fiche de la cgt qui
dénonce les violences policières avec
vantage
il ya cette image terrible avec cette
mare de sang et puis la police doit
protéger les citoyens et non les frapper
l'iton comment est ce que vous avez
réagi personnellement très mal je trouve
que c'est une affiche qui est hors de
propos de laisser penser comme ces
données avec cette affiche très
particulière que la police serait là
comme c'est dit pour frapper et nous
protéger on se rappelle quand même de ce
qui s'est passé
on se rappelle des attentats on se
rappelle du rôle et de la place de la
police
dans ces moments difficiles pour les
français il parfaitement mal venu et
c'est une affiche qui est condamnable
pour sa de laisser penser que la police
serait là pour frapper c'est pas vrai
bernard qui s'est indigné comme vous
doit porter plainte contre la cgt sait
ce qu on lui suggère à droite du côté là
bernard cazeneuve prendra les décisions
qui
sans qui sont les plus justes c'est à
lui de prendre ses décisions mais je
sais qu'il a été particulièrement
choquée par cette affiche est à juste
titre en rappelant d'ailleurs que dans
les méfaits de manifestation qui est 850
policiers qu'on établisse un survol
chacun doit être envoyée à ses
responsabilités alors je vous propose
d'écouter la réaction aujourd'hui du
numéro un de la cgt justement philippe
martinez je pense que le comme moi c'est
comme ça que j'ai vu j'ai lu cette
affiche c'est parler c'est pas ceux qui
appliquent les ordres qui sont montrés
du doigt
ce sont ceux qui donnent les ordres et
nous ont de ce point de vue là nous
allons discuter avec nos camarades de la
fédération de la police
et c'est comme ça on voit cette affiche
alors ce qui donne les ordres là encore
le numéro un de la cgt
cibler le gouvernement oui mais je crois
que là vous l'avez compris et vous
l'avez dit d'ailleurs en introduction de
l'avis de la cgt c'est de renvoyer la
responsabilité du gouvernement je peux
pas dire autre chose que c'est
totalement des accusations et cette
affiche est une accusation qui n'est pas
vrai et pas fondées les règles bernard
cazeneuve les a rappelés à chaque fois
c'est de chercher à éviter justement les
violences qu'on va pas rappeler aux
puces qui s'est passé après la levée des
nuits de boue il ya suffisamment de gens
qui ont été malheureusement montré pour
considérer que de temps en temps on peut
pas faire comme ça puisque on a respecté
et la police était là pour faire
respecter le fait qu' il y ait des
débats qui s'organise place de la
république
mais elle est là aussi pour faire
respecter le fait que derrière on ne
peut pas accepter qu'il y ait des
violences et que des casseurs du gens
cassent casse laissant penser à la
police d'avoir reçu la désordre pour
laisser faire en quelque sorte les cas
ça c'est encore mieux valait avoir
reproché à la police hier qui a reproché
sa lorsque la police quand la police est
intervenue quand la police a fait son
travail
la preuve c'est que monsieur martinez
j'ai à dire que c'était avec des ordres
justement oui pour éviter qu'ils aient
des violences éviter qu'on casse éviter
qu'on détruise mais oui par définition
est ce qu'il faut mais on peut leur
reprocher à l'état
sauf à penser qu'il faudrait laisser
tout le monde faire ce qu'il veut et ce
serait des premiers qui ensuite
viendrait nous dire qui
qu'on laisserait des casseurs entrent en
cause un un mouvement non ça n'est pas
sérieux tout ça est lié à une posture
d'entrée de congrès et tout ça a des
conséquences je pense d'abord les
conséquences et pour la france pour les
salariés cette capacité qu'on aurait
plutôt à devoir trouver des voies et des
moyens pour avancer dans des compromis
dans la sérénité là on est au contraire
dans un choix qui n'a choix durs et
extrêmement fermé ça je trouve que c'est
pas bon alors à propos de nu debout la
droite là vous demande de mettre fin à
l'occupation de la place de la
république à paris estimant que c'est
complètement aberrant en plein état
d'urgence et il l'intolérance l'aurait
emporté sur le dialogue aujourd'hui
oui il faut évacuer la place
écoutez ce qui s'est passé avec hugh
grant a été condamné je trouve aussi que
dans la démocratie
le plus dur c'est toujours d'accepter
qu'on est en face de soi des gens qui
pensent pas comme soi mais c'est comme
soi c'est ça l'enjeu de la démocratie et
c'est ce qui fait qu ensuite on essaie
de trancher avec des votes
donc au bout du compte c'est combien ce
système qui permet le mieux des
d'assurer la liberté d'expression et la
même chose qu alain finkielkraut qui me
la vidéo qui met des mots très forts lui
parce qu'il dénonce il est allé voir sur
place donc on sait comment ça s'est
passé pour lui ni ils dénoncent un
nouveau totalitarisme
oui mais la démocratie c'est votre
facture qu'ils ont fait et qui se sont
comportés comme ils se sont comportés
face à monsieur phil coke route ils ont
billets justement que la démocratie
c'est cette capacité à devoir échanger
et accepté les arguments et a cherché à
convaincre pas à exclure pas à empêcher
ces biens sujet donc c'est une notion
qui est à méditer pour tous ceux qui
font souvent comment dirais-je
profession de liberté de démocratie et
bien la démocratie c'est d'accepter les
avis divergent n'y a rien de positif
selon roulant fait rassemblement de même
s'il ya eu du jeu le 10e positive le
fait que des gens se saisissent de
sujets et et chercha débattent entre eux
c'est pas condamnable c'est bien pour ça
que quand je vois la droite qui
insistent lourdement pour dire il faut
l'interdire faut l'interdire
il ya des choses que bas au travers du
débat cette recherche des débats moi je
la respecte mais elle faux
qu'elle soit il faut aller jusqu'au bout
de la logique du cinéma et on va pas
dire que parce qu'on est un certain
nombre sur une place qu on aurait raison
contre tout le monde
alors elle sujet à une personnalité qui
a été très bien accueilli et place de la
république d'ailleurs peu avant
finkielkraut c'est yannis varoufakis
l'ancien ministre grec des finances
il a eu des mots assez durs pour
françois hollande 1 il lui a attribué un
zéro pointé aujourd'hui il estime qu'il
n'a rien fait pour sauver la grèce
contrairement à ce qu'il a dit en
revanche ils couvrent d'éloges emmanuel
macron comment est ce que vous comprenez
et correctement voyager c'est vous ce
jeu je me rends comprendre enfin je veux
ne pas chercher à comprendre
maintenant j'ai pas étonné puis on va
s'expliquer très clairement la question
de la grèce c'était quoi syriza c'était
monsieur de sipera ce avec monsieur la
fin ou factice comme ministre des
finances c'était de dire on ne veut pas
des contreparties qu'on nous demande
mais par contre on a besoin d'avoir un
financement pour l'état grec
bon au départ tout ça a été soutenue par
beaucoup d'ailleurs un qui ont vu la
capacité de renverser la table de
changer ce qui est la construction de
l'europe et pis au fur et à mesure parce
que le besoin était là ce type race a
fait des choix courageux et à la fois
respectant les grands enjeux qui étaient
ceux de la grèce mais il a fait des
choix
c'est d'avoir les financements et en
même temps accepter des contreparties
puisqu'on peut pas non plus considéré
qu' on va prêter
on va financer 100 kg et des
contreparties et pour ce qui est du rôle
de la france
le respect est parti il n'a pas suivi
mais ce type race je rappellerai que je
crois dans une partie de ceux qui ont
été aidées ceux qui ont été des fondeurs
ceux qui ont quitté syriza se sont
présentés aussi aux élections ils ont
fait qu un gain de 3%
donc monsieur varoufakis aujourd'hui ne
représente pas d'expression de ce qu'a
été le vote des crêtes et le choix
qu'elle a capté par monsieur de sipera
ces petites questions encore dans
l'actualité politique d'avoir eu en fait
une question économique à propos d'eads
et a figuré une réunion au sommet à
l'elysée pas protégé où je crois qu'il
ya une réunion demain voilà vous
confirmer que l'état soutient les
regrettés d'investissements risqués
dit-on en grande bretagne chez
l'opérateur
nous aurons un fonctionnaire dans l'état
où il est a présenté la grille à une
grande entreprise française l'état
s'énerve alors on vous prendre en compte
l'ensemble des enjeux et surtout la
pérennité de cette grande entreprise
bon ok on va attendre à l'oignon par
définition le pardonner les conclusions
puisque la vague il participe alors une
question politique après on a parlé
après de votre écrivain j'en parlais
tout à l'heure et où la gauche europe
ecologie les verts refusent de donner
une consigne de vote pour le second tour
de la législative partielle dans
l'ancienne circonscription de jean marc
ayrault et son rôle c'est ce sera un
duel entre le ps et les républicains
quelle est votre réaction vous êtes
entre kuala la colère et la
consternation de benoît où j'ai passé le
temps de la colère je suis assez
consterné par cette hausse permet et
consterné parce qu'au fond tout ça c'est
pour quels objectifs de considérer que
jusqu'au bout on va se faire la guerre
entre nous et à la limite mais ça se
passera pas parce que les électeurs qui
viendront et je les appelle à venir
voter pour la candidate socialiste qui a
fait une très belle campagne je la
connais bien
karine et j'appelle à ce que tout le
monde se mobilise et aillent voter au
deuxième tour mais ça serait de faire
passer candidat républicain le
républicain candidat qui de toute façon
sur la question de notre dame des landes
est favorable à notre dame des landes
aussi donc qu'est-ce que ça veut dire se
fait dès dvd
on se fait du mal à nous mêmes la gauche
est capable d'aller jusqu'au bout d'une
logique qui consiste à empêcher le parti
socialiste de pouvoir remporter ce siège
au nom de débats qui font que toute
façon si ce n'était pas la gauche ça
serait la droite et que la droite a pris
position de manière très claire et sur
beaucoup d'autres sujets qui sont en
totale contradiction avec ce que
souhaitent europe écologie verts donc
c'est incompréhensible
avec moi j'appelle tous les électeurs
ont voté au premier tour pour un verre
de voter au deuxième
vous êtes concernés à l'heure l'on
grandisse on se fait du mal à nous même
dit vous stéphane le foll ce sera
justement le thème de la deuxième
question de cette émission pouvez vous
nous confirmer que face aux divisions de
votre camp et bien votre crise est au la
gauche avec un meeting donc lundi soir
vous allez le dire à oriane mancini
public sénat mais sommes-nous entrés
déjà dans l'après hollande la question
n'est pas tabou à gauche
alors que des sondages en rafales encore
aujourd'hui indique que le chef de
l'état serait absent du second tour quel
que soit l'adversaire de droite nathalie
gilbert vient d'interroger david revault
d'allonnes du monde
françois hollande ne renoncera pas à la
candidature il l'a montré ces derniers
jours leur sens de sa récente interview
télévisée il ira jusqu'au bout et
c'était une interview de traits candidat
donc lui ne veut pas renoncer
il ya le clan des hollandais
traditionnels ce sont toujours les mêmes
jean yves le drian michel sapin françois
rebsamen
et puis bien sûr il y a stéphane le foll
qui est sans doute le premier des
grognards le premier des soldats de
françois hollande depuis toujours
enfin depuis très longtemps en tout cas
et qui le restera jusqu'au bout bonsoir
également que ce n'est celle des fans de
folk grognards donc on sort ses fans le
fun bonjour le premier grognards de
françois hollande
vous cherchez votre armée c'est pour ça
que vous lancez et où la gauche lundi
prochain non je lançais où la gauche
c'est pour rappeler à la gauche que ce
qu'on a fait on ne va pas le cacher mais
on va aussi en être fier et que tous les
procès qui ont été faits et j'en ai
entendu mais des dizaines sur la
trahison et et des mots terribles sur
françois hollande c'est pire que nicolas
sarkozy ce que je voulais avec d'autres
ministres c'est de rappeler que nous
nous avons fait des choses sous les 4
ans avec françois hollande jean-marc
ayrault et manuel valls
et nous en sommes fiers si on regarde
sur les questions de la santé ce qui a
été fait par mme marisol touraine si on
regarde ce qui a été fait sur les
questions de l'éducation
si on regarde ce qui a été fait dans la
question du logement et de l'accès au
logement
et tout ça sont des choses qu'on va
revendiquer pour dire hé ho
la gauche a critiqué on est ne pas vous
tromper
nous on défend ce que neuf son envie
d'entendre les langues rares nations
fait comment c'est aux éau la gauche
écoutez on ne voudrait bien entendu les
procès continue eh bien on va vous
montrer que nous nous avons fait des
choses et des choses qui sont tout à
fait conformes aux valeurs de la gauche
alors comment va se passer concrètement
ce rassemblement qui sera présent ou
comment il va se passer sur les grandes
questions sociales et éducatives ca les
grands sujets
est lié au modèle social c'est ça
l'enjeu de du lundi 25 mai sied de
rappeler ce qu'on a fait était de dire
en même temps à écouter et c'est la
démocratie
on y revient qu'est-ce qui est
l'alternative
qu'est ce que propose la droite ce qu'on
a tendance à l'oublier ont d'ailleurs eu
d'amendé qui sera là les jeux il y aura
najat vallaud-belkacem éducation marisol
touraine la santé et m'accostent la
question de logement
et puis sur le parti radical de gauche
jean-michel baylet ou sylvia pinel et
puis d'autres ministres qui viendront
équipe daniel aussi s'exprimer mais des
milices qui viendront et c'est quelqu'un
qui sait que manuel valls
je pense que le premier ministre
aujourd'hui et les ministres qui sont
chargés des grandes responsabilités
régaliennes je les dis on dit sur le
sujet éducation santé
c'est la question du modèle social c'est
une étape le premier ministre bien sûr
est parfaitement au courant mais ça met
la min sera pas là alors quelles raisons
mais pour quelle raison parce que le
premier ministre a la responsabilité
devant son gouvernement sur tous les
sujets mais pas simplement exceptionnel
parce qu'il est trop trop clivant non
d'abord c'est pas que des hollandais
puisque j'ai bien entendu cela dit ce
qui était fait et moi je ne revendique
pas d'être le dernier grognard ou
d'avoir été dernier effectivement je
revendique qu'une chose c'est quoi tient
une tempête
moi je suis capable de mettre le ciré et
de tenir ça c'est la seule expérience
que je revendique même pas vrai même
temps fort ce 8 mai mme perfore suivi de
quelques fois ça c'est ce que je
revendique le reste et bien les
ministres qui sont là et qui n'ont pas
été tous des hollandais comme c'était
dix sont là pour défendre aussi ce que
nous avons fait et les valeurs que nous
défendons
je pense que c'est sale interpellations
et au la gauche peut pas nous dire et
nous reprocher tout et son contraire et
surtout regarde et où la gauche regarde
ce qu'ont fait par la droite
on a bien compris qu'il sera là du coup
on a envie de vous demander qui ne sera
pas là est ce qu emmanuel macron sera
présent ou par nom emmanuel macron mais
non plus c'est là qu'il n'est pas là on
nage ou lady le champ du social
le champ de l'éducation je crois pas que
dans la région ce match l'ex n 2
emmanuel macron ce soit
sujets qu'ils soient directement qui
concerne directement et emmanuel macron
d'ailleurs je vais vous savez très bien
et ça va être le sujet suivant a
lui-même créé un mouvement qui s'appelle
en marche donc il a aussi sa
responsabilité ils l'assument et nous on
a affaire aussi valoir ce que nous avons
fait dans ce domaine du modèle social en
reprenant dire la sq a dit le président
de la république j'ai préservé
on a adapté ce modèle social mais on a
donné des droits nouveaux aux français
et ça c'est important de voir que quand
on vous entend et au la gauche a pour
but de réveiller le clivage droite
gauche qu'est le contraire de ce que
veut faire emmanuel macron avec en arche
lui veut travailler avec des hommes de
droite mais j'ai bien vous avez
parfaitement comment telle chose
donc moi je suis là pour dire que on
s'adresse à ceux qui doutent aujourd'hui
je m'adresse pas aux responsables
politiques de ne pas chercher à
convaincre jean luc mélenchon je suis
pas j'ai pas cette ambition là mais je
cherche à aller avec les ministres y
sont le 25 à les rappeler ceux qui
doutent et qui doute parce que beaucoup
entendre que les critiques et on ne
défend pas assez ce qu'on a fait ça je
suis convaincu depuis longtemps je n'ose
s'aventurer prix il faut défendre ce
qu'on a fait et il faut être fier de ce
qu'on a fait on a compris mon message
mais ce que vous êtes en concurrence
avec eux en opposition plutôt comme le
disait effectivement rien avec le
ministre d'économie qui lui veut joindre
les deux bouts et non l'accusé dans nos
positions du tout le joint mais je
prends une opposition moi je suis pas là
dans un débat avec emmanuel macron je
suis un débat je vous le rappelle pour
aller convaincre ceux qui aujourd'hui
doute de nous et comme je constate que
depuis longtemps on ne parle pas de ce
qu'on a fait dans une dans un moment
économique difficile avec une menace
terroriste qui a été celle qu'on a
connue avec une menace sur l'europe on
en parlait tout à l'heure avec la grèce
aida sortie de l'euro dans ces moments
là on a préservé et ça c'est très
important un modèle social qu'on a
adapté question des retraites
en même temps on a offert la possibilité
de partir à 60 ans pour ceux qu'avait
leur durée de cotisation
on a même introduit la pénibilité qui
fait pas plaisir à monsieur gattaz mais
qui
quand je lis le livre de seniors qui
dans l'abattoir raconte son histoire
pourrait tenir comme ça mais on va vous
dire toujours à chaque fois mais vous
avez aggraver le chômage alors sur la
question du chômage
là oui mais je peux dire aussi que quand
on a mis en place et marisol touraine de
dira très bien et mieux que moi le tiers
payant quand tu l'as mis en place
l'universalité des droits sociaux à la
sécurité sociale
quand on ya mis en place les retraites
complémentaires pour tous les salariés
on a eu vraiment pour l'ensemble des
salariés français devraient sur les
valeurs de la gauche
mutualisation solidarité et en même
temps on travaille aussi donner aux
entreprises c'est une pac de
responsabilité les capacités de pouvoir
faire face
or il ya concurrence on comprend bien de
ce que vous avez fait stéphane minguet
quand on entend françois hollande dire
jeudi dernier que ça va mieux
alors certes il ya tout ce que vous avez
fait mais il ya aussi tout ce que vous
n'avez pas fait effectivement le chômage
augmente plus de 22% sur son quinquennat
la croissance est toujours en dessous de
la moyenne de la zone euro le déficit a
baissé certes mais moins que celui des
autres pays de la zone euro est ce que
vous comprenez les français qui pensent
que quand françois hollande il ça c'est
un déni de réalité
j'ai pas déni de réalité on arrive sur
des baissiers de vous expliquer quand on
arrive il est à combien le déficit
budgétaire 3.5 non mais non tout cinq et
demi pour cent je suis désolé à vous
regarderez les chiffres on est
aujourd'hui à 3,5 on avait prévu trois
derniers étés à 4,8 il est 3 heures et à
+25 2011 mais on arrive en 2012
on a fait suffisamment reproche aux
lavier nominaux de suite à 3% en irak à
la fin de l'année remis à 3% tout de
suite
ah oui mais peut-être à 340 me suis dit
moi je veux bien compromettre tous en
course mais il faut reprendre ce qui
avait été dit à l'époque et sur quelle
base
ça avait été calculé quand on arrive et
qu'on s'aperçoit je prends l'entreprise
peugeot c'est pas une entreprise
aujourd'hui qui s'est redressée car
distribuer des salaires et des primes
aux salariés qui va recréer de l'emploi
quand on arrive je vous rappelle l été
oui mais pratiquement veut pas regarder
dans les situations et d'affirmer sans
tenir compte du contexte européen certes
il a baissé il est passé de 4 85 si vous
voulez à 3 aujourd'hui soit une baisse
de trois points dans le reste de la zone
euro il a baissé de 1,7 point
mais parce qu'on fait un choix mais
attendez on fait un choix qui est
d'aller au rythme que la france peut à
la fois assumer et accepté début les
débats qu'on a rien n'est facile c'est à
dire que la zone euro mais c'est parce
que les pays sont dans d'autres
dividendes ou dans d'autres situations
si je prends la question de l'espagne à
quel niveau et le chômage global à plus
de 23 24 ans sans même en italie
comprend souvent comme exemple je le
disais au passage on est à plus de 11%
sur le chômage global donc on peut faire
des comparaisons faut-il les faire
d'ailleurs sur la question du chômage
avec les chiffres eurostat et pas
comparer pôle emploi et des chiffres
eurostat dans les autres pays sur la
question de la crise en espagne
c'est une crise qui fait que la
croissance aujourd'hui est encore plus
fait même si elle se redresse et c'est
tant mieux pour l'espagne et s'est
redressée mais à quel niveau était la
récession en espagne
elle n'a pas idée à ce niveau là en
france donc c'est ça que je veux dire je
veux dire que dans ce moment difficile
alors on fait des comparaisons quand ça
arrange mais la réalité c'est que ça va
mieux quand vous les mains géantes
ivement sauf sur un point sur la
question du chômage
sauf si je mets de côté la baisse du
chômage des jeunes où on a fait mieux
que globalement sous chômage et que sur
ce sujet du chômage c'est bien parce que
l'économie ira mieux qu'on finira pas
faire baisser le chômage
alors vous parliez tout à l'heure de
ceux qui doutent ils sont nombreux
françois hollande qui a la cote de
popularité la plus faible d'un président
de la république à un an de la fin de
son mandat les sondages qui le donnent
éliminé dès le premier tour est ce qu'il
doit renoncer à se présenter
non mais la pression qu'ils posent et
qui vous a été posée d'ailleurs dans les
jours et j'ai bien vu un et
jean-christophe comédie ça très bien
fait ce matin de le dire qui consiste à
tomber comme ça avec tous les sondages
est à prendre comme seule question d
alors est ce que il va pouvoir se
représenter
c'est un sujet qui peut intéresser je
vais parfaitement conscience je vous
laisse là dessus tout la liberté qu'il
faut pour pouvoir le commenter mais moi
je vais pas commenter ça j'avoue
elle-même à répondre à des questions de
sondage
mon expérience je voulais dit quand il
s'est agi de mettre que le cir est dans
la tempête
si je me rappelais tout ce que j'ai
entendu de la part des journalistes et
des commentateurs et descendeur fut un
temps elle me rappelle très bien tête à
trois portes jeu
koné tout ça par coeur donc ça c'est une
expérience que j'ai acquis c'est ce que
je vous ai dit je revendique pas grand
chose ça au moins je sais je sais aussi
ne pas répondre et ne pas m'engager sur
les débats sur des photos qui sont
données et puis tout de suite tout le
monde a ri hollande machine comme l'a
très bien dit gens puissent s'opposer
je pense que ça suffit cette faute d'un
système nous c'est pas la faute
d'assystem je sais ce qu'est volant de
bâches et un concert le 10 stations figo
sondages il a dit ce matin je pense que
ce qui était très bien dit c'est que le
holland machine je dis stop
alors ça pendant la question de sa
candidature va se poser d'ici la fin de
l'année l'a dit lui même
est-ce que lui qui était premier
secrétaire du ps le 21 avril 2002 il
peut endosser la responsabilité de voix
on est au mois d'avril on est au made
man et donc les décisions seront prises
à la fin d'année l'année prochaine si on
est au mois d'avril on sera en 2010 est
bon donc le commentaire sur l'hypothèse
qui serait celle de il est clair
qu'aujourd'hui le niveau élevé du front
national 13 bd front national ne doit
pas laisser de doute sur le risque qui
peut y avoir des nappes sens de candidat
de gauche au deuxième tour
c'est très clair ça c'est vrai mais
après pas rentrer dans les détails et
toutes les spéculations alors vous allez
me dire là aussi ce que ce ne sont que
des sondages mais dans ces sondages jean
luc mélenchon fait un score très élevé
est-ce que ça illustre le fait qu'il ya
désormais deux gauches irréconciliables
non ça dit 'je te pack de gauche on
cible est irréconciliable salle des
illustres le fait justement qu'il faut
qu'on reparle aussi à la gauche
voilà donc vous avez avec votre question
nous permis au ministre que je suis de
répondre aussi à l'initiative et au la
gauche
aujourd'hui je préférais conseiller mais
là c'est paris de gauche qui peuvent
sans séquelles et l'électorat qui est
prêt qui a déjà voté pour les sociétés
je rappelle et on oublie tout ça mais
c'est normal aux élections régionales
les résultats du parti socialiste par
rapport à ceux du front de gauche et
europe écologie verts c'est assez clair
il n'y a pas eu dans toute les partiels
qui ont eu qui se sont déroulées hier la
cd partiel c'est des votes avec des taux
d'abstention qui pouvait élever sur les
régionales ça va monter mais deux
candidats du front
le candidat du front de gauche de liste
du front de gauche qui passe devant le
parti socialiste
donc vous voyez bien qu'il faut tout
relativisé jeudi toujours qu'un sondage
c'est un moment donné bon c'est sûr mais
ça donne pas le climat
au moment des élections y'a pas tes
sandales par exemple j'ai dû amener
d'algos qui dit et qui pensent que la
sanction va être terrible oui je pense
pas que ça soit de bonne méthode
d'annoncer le pire
je pense qu'il ya des moments où on peut
considérer qu'on est moins d'accord je
sais qu'à 10 algo sur un certain nombre
de sujets n'est pas d'accord elle est
soi-même se projeter en disant ça va
être le pire c'est pas une manière me
semble-t-il
après chacun fait ce qu'il veut de faire
oeuvre pour son camp est utile
après on peut discuter un nouveau les
questions identifiées voilà c'est pas
bien sa petite ses déclarations dans vsd
on verra ça vient d'annoncer comme ça
voilà comme ça je peux pas dire autre
chose on va écouter un autre proche de
françois hollande depuis longtemps c'est
jean pierre mignard qui demande au chef
de l'état s'il veut repartir à la
campagne au combat d'avoir un projet
fracassant question de françois hollande
je vais vous dire il pense qu'on peut
faire les choses sans aller jusqu'à
crhiv et il n'aime pas les débats
fracassant il n'aime pas les grands
affrontements et il pense que l'on peut
faire est que en faisant est bien petit
à petit cela va infuser ça suffit eh
bien je pense que justement ce n'est
plus possible aujourd'hui et qu'il doit
prendre des responsabilités publiques y
compris au risque de sa non élection
mais pour faire avancer le pays vous
êtes d'accord avec ce nom je suis pas je
suis pas d'accord sur la question du
frat assange entendu par exemple
françois fillon qui veut casser la
baraque or justement c'est l'ambition du
pays avant son ambition personnelle
comme ça c'est autre chose c'est ce que
tu dis ça c'est autre chose on m'avait
posé une présentation sur le fracassant
je ne crois pas et d'ailleurs les
commentaires que je faisais sur la
posture et la position de la cgt
c'est justement parce que je pense qu'on
a besoin justement de sortir de ces
idées du fracas et que s'il ya un sens à
donner à ce qui a été le
la présidence de françois hollande c'est
que justement il a cherché à éviter le
fracas et bien dans un moment aussi
grave que ce qu'on a traversé en partie
en particulier en 2015
je pense que jean pierre mignard a
oublié mais je pense que c'est justement
parce que il a été capable d'éviter le
frattin qu'on a réussi à éviter la
cassure dire surtout que il faut à
françois hollande peut-être un petit peu
plus de tempérament
peut-être une question un peu plus
personnelle puisque vous lorsque vous
étiez à solférino pendant de longues
années aux côtés de françois hollande
vous étiez pour lui l'homme qui disait
non à sa place est ce que c'est ce qui a
manqué à françois hollande durant ce
quinquennat
j'en sais rien la situation au parti
socialiste à l'époque premier secrétaire
directeur de cabinet on va là même que
quand on est à la tête de l'état parce
que la tête de l'état on a d'autres
enjeux il ya d'autres camps dirais-je
institutions bon donc il n'ya pas de
comparaison à faire
vous avez vu ce dessin amusant l'autre
jour dans l'opinion on vous voit avec un
tatouage françois hollande
pas question bien sûr pour vous de
l'enlever 1 1
j'ai pas vu ça manque un titre et le
monde magasin ce sera vous oh moi je
suis tatouée pour la vie un homme c'est
sincère et loyal oui ça fait partie des
suppositions des qualités on finit pas
s'en douter mais moi je resterai comme
je suis donc j'ai été sincère dans tout
ce que j'ai fait on viendra sur les
questions agricoles
c'est la conviction et loyal parce que
moi je n'ai jamais et vous pourrez
toujours regarder dit des mots qui
pouvait mettre en difficulté l'équipe à
laquelle j'appartenais que ce soit sous
jean marc ayrault manuel valls ou même
avant et j'ai toujours eu cette ligne de
conduite donc ça restera jusqu'au bout
très bien vous appréciez le fait que
macron acceptent d'aller à orléans pour
la fête de jeanne d'arc le 8 mai à
l'invitation du maire les républicains
moi je trouve que bon ça dépend qui sont
des symboles qu'on veut mettre en avant
moi je marque je respecte oui
fournisseurs et l'histoire mais je pense
qu'il ya en ce moment des symboles plus
fort qu'il faut valoriser
je pense que cette belle devise de la
république liberté indispensable
l'égalité avec la solidarité et la
fraternité
ça mérite d'être plutôt mis en avant les
jeunes rats on la laisse à d'autres ou 9
pas laisser dorer non ça retient ils
vont pas la laisser nous appartient tous
d'accord mais vous ne seriez pas aller à
orléans le lui mais on n'a que je crains
que je n'ai pas été honorées per ne
serait pas allé vous ne seriez pas aller
voilà c'est clair et notre merci mais je
n'aurais pas été invitée aussi d'accord
merci beaucoup à ryadh troisième
question de preuves par 3 maintenant la
crise agricole donc est ce que le pire
est encore à venir vous allez le dire à
anne chaon de la sp la présence d'un
agriculteur face à françois hollande
lors de son dialogue citoyen l'autre
soir sur france 2 aurait permis un de
rappeler que la crise agricole est bien
toujours là mais on n'a pas convié à au
prétexte que la crise ne serait plus
d'actualité ce n'est évidemment pas le
cas comme nous le dit jérémy decerle le
vice président des jeunes agriculteurs
je pense qu on y est déjà dans le pire
toutes les productions sont sont touchés
alors d'une manière différente pour
chacune
là aucune aucune des filières net
épargné par par cette crise et donc du
coup ce qu'on sent peut-être c'est que
le gouvernement et peut-être aussi le
ministre ont pris conscience de la
gravité de cette crise peut être un peu
un peu tardivement ou en tous cas ont
mis les moyens pour essayer de faire
face à cette crise un peu tardivement
voilà bonsoir nous avons cette fois vos
questions aux ministres de l'agriculture
le ministre comme vient de le dire
jérémy de cernay le monde agricole vous
a reproché d'avoir laissé un petit peu
filer cette crise depuis l'été dernier
on n'est pas loin du milliard d'euros
quand on met bout à bout toutes les
aides les allègements de charges
est-ce que de votre point de vue ça va
mieux dans les campagnes
d'abord pour répondre à la question est
ce que j'aurai laissé 2 j'aurais pas
perçu la crise je vous rappelle que dès
février 2015
dès février 2015 je suis déjà sur des
plans avec quelques allègements sur le
budget de l'agriculture de charge parce
que j'ai parfaitement conscience que
soit la filière porcine en particulier
ça va déjà très mal qu'on a fait des
tables rondes assez rapidement pour
négocier et je les fais dès 2014 a fait
hurler les grands enjeux des discussions
et des négociations commerciales entre
la grande distribution et
les industriels et donc les producteurs
donc je crois pas que je laissé filer
sans avoir perçu là que j'ai
parfaitement mesuré après elle s'est
approfondie elle c est devenu de plus en
plus forte en particulier sur la filière
porcine
avec l'été qu'on a connu et avec sur la
filière laitière le fait qu'au fur et à
mesure on passe dans une situation où la
production dépasse largement la demande
et que la chine après avoir beaucoup
acheté en 2014 a beaucoup limité ses
achats en 2015 qui a fait l'engorgement
de cette production est ce que vous
n'êtes pas de toute façon condamné a
écopé la mer avec une petite tasse parce
que vous serez toujours les le monde
agricole sera sur tributaire des grands
marchés mondiaux et le monde agricole
est tributaire à la fois des marchés
mondiaux et des marchés locaux et on
développe les marchés locaux mais il est
tributaire c'est vrai des marchés
mondiaux je prends la question des
céréales quand je suis arrivé en 2012 on
était autour de 270 euros la tonne on
est passé il ya pas longtemps c'est une
marche et chicago qui le dit
malheureusement à 130 m en dessous de
130 euros la tonne quand sur le lait ces
deux marchés chinois et la grande partie
du marché asiatique définit le prix de
la poudre de lait ça a des répercussions
donc c'est vrai et ça c'est extrêmement
difficile à expliquer et quand les
agriculteurs viennent jusqu'à chez moi
pour me dire mais qu'est ce que vous
faites sur les prix je suis là en face
d'une responsabilité qui est de dire la
vérité et en même temps d'essayer de
trouver des voies et des moyens pour
éviter le pire trouver des solutions ça
fait partie du plan que nous avons
présentés avec manuel valls à deux
reprises en juillet et en septembre il
faudra faire autre alors si on écoutait
n 1 ça dépend de la situation des
démarches et est-ce qu'ils vont
s'équilibrer à nouveau ce que je
souhaite vous avez parlé prise là dessus
mais c'est extrêmement difficile d'avoir
une prix alors j'ai une prise c'est ce
que j'ai essayé de faire comprendre à
l'échelle européenne
en dix ans au dernier conseil de
l'agriculture qu'on pouvait pas
continuer à stocker je voyais les images
juste avant du débat au sénat à stocker
pratiquement le double de ce qu'on a
stocké l'an dernier en poudre de lait
sans considérer qu'il ya un problème de
surproduction
parce que les mêmes qui disent c'est
l'économie et c'est de marcher mais qui
ne trouvant pas de débouchés vont saisir
et appelé la commission pour stocker de
la poudre
froid qui m'explique qu'est ce que c'est
que ce marché c'est simple si on avait
une europe qui parlait d'une seule voix
ils revus n'empêche que j'ai réussi à
faire comprendre qu'on était dans une
phase de surproduction et que là on
avait besoin de revenir un minimum de
d'organisation au travers d'un article
que nous avons pu retirer proposées pour
faire en sorte qu'on stabilise la
production et ça c'est colossal
mais maintenant ce que je dis aussi et
c'est ça qui me frappe c'est que ous au
niveau politique on a réussi à faire
bouger les choses maintenant on va aller
au parlement européen le 25 mai on va
pousser pour avoir une décision
européenne
les interprofessions française s'est mis
d'accord mais ce que je constate c'est
que au niveau des syndicats de
producteurs à l'échelle européenne
il se l'est le syndicat allemand
majoritaire il dit c'est de marcher
c'est le marché alors que parce qu'ils
ne sont adaptés et au niveau dés qu ici
c'était la vérité ils n'iraient pas
l'intervention
donc c'est ça que je redis on pourrait
me dire on s'est adapté et vous vous
avez été complètement dépassé mais je
constate que la plupart des pays qui ont
augmenté le plus leur production sont
ceux qui ont recours le plus à
l'intervention donc ils peuvent pas me
dire que c'est parce qu'ils se sont
adaptés par les finitions sont pas
adaptés puisqu'une partie de cette
production va en stockage public
aujourd'hui
donc là je le dis je le répète et je
vais mener cette bataille
j'ai déjà gagné sur le plan politique
maintenant il faut qu'on la mette en
oeuvre concrètement et vous n'avez pas
tout à fait réconcilier le votre point
de vue est celui de la fnsea vous avez
non j'ai constaté qu'effectivement j'ai
été accueilli chaleureusement
voilà vous avez votre votre serrure vous
y attendiez bruit je suis je m'y
attendais j'avais invité avec insistance
donc j'ai respecté l'invitation ne pas
dire que lorsque vous êtes invités
quelque part il est habituel d'avoir ce
type d'accueil mais moi je respecte la
fnsea j'ai toujours respecté mais j'ai
aussi des divergences je vais vous dire
une chose
j'ai eu des divergences et sur la
question du plan ecophyto 2 qui va
recycler a baissé bien on a mis enfin en
place
ce certificat d'économie de produits
phytosanitaires
je les vis dans un communiqué une
première en europe je pense que c'est
même une première dans le monde
je le dis ce soir devant vous une
première dans le monde où tous les
acteurs et j'ai négocié ça parce qu'au
départ il avait d
discussions extrêmement dur sur cette
question et ils ont fait des
propositions on à négocier aussi avec
murat sur des indicateurs qui soit
encore à composer d'ecophyto de
l'ambition c'est de moitié d'ici 2020
soit l'âge des produits mais pour la
première fois même dans lequel la france
est championne faudra bout et elle est
championne
oui faut relativiser ça elle est
championne parce que on a la plus grande
surface agricole et si on prend le
volume total bien sûr comme il ya la
première agriculture on qu'on n'achète
où on n'utilise plus de phytosanitaires
d'ici on ramène ça à l'hectare accord on
n'est pas du tout des champions 1
on est même dans la moyenne et pas du
tout des supers consommateurs de
phytosanitaires mais ça n'empêche que
moi je suis partisan de faire baisser
cette consommation phytosanitaires et
bien aujourd'hui puisque c'est sa date
d'aujourd'hui un éco phyto 2 ce plan va
être mis en place avec des certificats
d'économies de phytosanitaires je crois
je suis à peu près sûr c'est une
première européenne
et c'est une première mondiale et ça a
été négocié avec ceux qui vendent les
producteurs la effet les soirs les
coopératives et aussi les associations
environnement avec des sanctions à la
clé avec des sanctions actuelles qui
pèseront sur qui qui pèseront sur ceux
qui vendent les distraits c'est ça la
nouveauté est au bout de cinq ans
puisqu'on a donné cinq ans on dira voilà
baissé de 20%
les scientifiques qui va baisser de 20%
la vente de phytosanitaires et si ces
faits qui a aucune sanction
cinq ans pour faire vos choix et on
mesurera les efforts au travers des
certificats et on vous donnera des
certificats qui permettent de constater
d'adresser une décision unilatérale de
la france ça c'est une décision
correspond à l'engagement européen sur
la directive d'accord ce défi tôt tout
le monde n'a pas la même position et
pesticides c'est la grande question
exactement et c'est bien pourquoi avoir
serré sur river je vais venir mais j'ai
exactement pourquoi j'irai au niveau
européen aussi présenté ce qu'a fait la
france est une vraie démarche qui n'est
pas une démarche de normes qui est une
marge de 2 création d'un système qui met
tout le monde autour d'une table pour
aboutir c'est là je reviens au compromis
aussi cette capacité qu'ont à discuter
ensuite sens des objectifs a cherché à
les atteindre ensemble
que vous craignez pas une fois de plus
de charger un petit peu la barque ce
qu'on vous reproche toujours de vouloir
être le plus vertueux le plus vert et la
barque et le sac à dos est plus lourd
pour le paysan français que pour son
voisin allemand espagnol
moi ce que je cherche c'est à combiner
les objectifs économiques c'est pour ça
que la discussion sur ico phyto et les
certificats d'économie de
phytosanitaires a porté aussi sur cette
dimension économique et la dimension
environnementale parce que je crois que
les deux sont ces habitations qui est en
cours je pense que la france si elle est
capable de se mettre en ordre avec des
agriculteurs qui sont des grands
professionnels aura un avantage
compétitif demain par rapport à d'autres
pays
merci ont bien sûr la cerise oui est ce
qu'on y est on en droit des cerises
française cette dernière question les
premières questions qu'est ce qui s'est
passé dans 16 n'a pas donné
d'autorisation sur ce produit n'est ni
frion par risque de pénurie ou pas aisée
mais vous voyez comment vous n'êtes pas
ce que va prendre expliqué le nord
d'abord on expliqué et après on va
répondre à la question
donc première chose se produit à deux
n'a pas l'autorisation de lancer ce donc
je saisis l'europe
à 10 ans c'est quand même bizarre il ya
d'autres pays on me dit qu'il donne des
autorisations sur un produit et moi mon
agent scientifique me dit il ya un
risque pour les consommateurs
bon on va effectivement constate qu'au
niveau européen c'est le flou le plus
total nous suivent pour dire on interdit
l'espagne l'italie et puis maintenant la
pologne semble trois pays sur wii mais
séquelles qui produisent un script oui
3 puis sur youtube mais vous savez en
lettonie en lituanie n'y a pas de
production de choses je vous dis au
passage de rapport dont le seul vrai
donc à partir de là ce qu'on dit les
producteurs eu d'accord nous on va nous
interdire
et puis on va importer et puis on va
pouvoir consommer des cerises qui sont
considérées comme dangereuses pas
dangereuse qui reçoit un petit risque
pour le consommateur mais elles vont
être apportées nous nous aurait interdit
parfaitement légitime double atos de
sauvegarde que vos tiers le fait que
tous les pays qui autoriseront par
dérogation d'utilisation d'une étoile
sur des cerises ne pouvons pas exporter
de cerises en france donc ça c'est un
point très fort quand les jurés sera
publié quand la l'arrêté sur demain
après demain on a vu ça avec les
professeurs je rajoute un point parce
qu'il est très important puisque vous
dites est ce qu'il y aura une pénurie
personne ne peut me le dire aujourd'hui
je ne sais pas on a offert
billy tong a offert des alternatives on
va essayer de travailler ensemble avec
les profits mais je vais le dire au
consommateur maintenant les cerises
française pour le coup parce que comme
si j'avais fait autrement on me dira m
sominice vous avez pris un risque
on n'a pas pris ce risque est tous
ensemble mais maintenant je dis aux
consommateurs les cerises française eh
bien elle ne nous ne n'auront pas
recours à ce produit
donc si vous voulez manger des cerises
moi j'ai plus les free seul en 16 / on
verra ce qu'on aura
mais les françaises sont des stries ski
bakker sont garantis et donc vous pouvez
en qu'on soit encore parce que c'est ça
le message positif +3 pour les questions
d'accord c'est très court ben on va
enchaîner sur le jour et quand même
juste convient à tout petit peu aux
normes ce que vous avez mis en place une
commission de 2 d'allègement et de
révision des normes
on va avoir les premières conclusions de
ce pur mois de juin le 23 juin on fera
une nuit de l'agro écologie puisque moi
j'aime bien débattre mais avec des
sujets concrets donc ce sera posée comme
un élément du débat d'ici le 23 juin
aura un certain nombre de critères qui
permettront de justifier le fait que des
normes qui existent aujourd'hui d'accord
peuvent être levés la luge avance mais
j'avance avec cette idée simple il y
avait d'énormes ce parce qu'il y avait
des pulsions si on a des modèles de
production qui permettent de ne plus de
jus de ne plus avoir de pollution qui a
pas de raison d'avoir les normes ça
l'enjeu et ses 5 ans mettra en place des
normes c'est très bien si ceux ci on a
des terres est ce que vous avez vu que
dès 6h chinois ont mis les pieds dans le
berry parcourir les 200 hectares et
surtout ils ont avancé masqué donc au
nez à la barbe des autorités et de la
safer chargé de surveiller l'aménagement
rural des pays comme la pologne du sud
en prix des lois parfois assez durs pour
interdire les investissements étrangers
dans le foncier agricole on peut
envisager ça entre nous on a un système
qui s'appellerait sa ferme qui donne un
droit de préemption à l'animisme en
public piqué unique pratiquement en
europe ou bien fonctionné la roumanie là
c'est des formes sociétaires et on a eu
ce débat pendant la loi d'avenir et à
l'époque s'est pas passé sur les
antennes pour justement redonner des
pouvoirs et plus de pouvoir aux affaires
il se trouve que là il ya un biais
puisque si l'ensemble ou société
tranche mais pas l'ensemble des terres
la safer n'est pas informée d'où le fait
qu'il y avait 1 10% des terres de
l'ensemble j'étais gardé et donc la
safer n'a pas pu savoir donc je vais
quasiment d'air
je vais et j'ai demandé parce qu'on
avait été jusqu'au bout de ce qui nous
était donné comme permission juridique
constitutionnel
je veux faire barrage aux chiens je veux
considérer que la terre france va la
terre la production en france et la
terre en france doit revenir à des
agriculteurs qui s'installent dès qu'ils
investissent mais ne pas accepter
effectivement que l'ensemble des
hectares en france puissent être
rachetée par d'autre part des pays en
plus un ça c'est un sujet sur lequel l'
alerte est clairement donné je vais
mettre en place juridiquement avec le
conseil général de l'agriculture une
mission pour qu'on évalue et qu'on me
dise comment on peut faire pour empêcher
que les safer n'ai pas pu repérer ce qui
s'était passé
non le berry ça s'est passé ces
dernières années louis halley ce que la
possibilité de savoir si ça s'est passé
ailleurs que dans le berry même si ça
s'est passé dans le berry
ça aurait pu mais je n'ai pas
d'information sur le sujet par
définition puisque on ne le sait pas
très bien merci anne merci c'est pas de
ma faute d'avoir été avec nous cette
semaine
merci bonsoir à tous et la semaine
prochaine c'est gérard larcher le
président du sénat qui sera l'invité de
preuves par 3 a très vite bonsoir